hello everybody my name is Marc Blair
and welcome to let's play
markiplier the game now if you haven't
seen the first one oh this is markiplier
of the game too by the way if you
haven't seen the first one check the
link in the description or look up on my
channel mark above the game big blue
background my face almost - ok let's go
let's start the madness mister now the
developer has been staring through your
windows for a number of months he has
calculated the perfect experience just
for you oh just for me oh boy I can't
wait is gonna be phenomenal
this is uhm lovely white space that you
have here I'm not going in there whoa
hey there pretty lady wait a minute is
that Mears that I think that's me ah
well that's a developer you couldn't
have made a creepier face if you had
tried oh that's me ok well there we have
it and is there a point to being in this
house is there a reason for me to be
here
hello mr. developer are you doing I hope
that's the developer otherwise if that's
that way is that actually me oh that
might actually just be a morphed out
version that one ok then Oh
I wasn't there before hello I was pretty
sure is this a self-destruct button to
end this torment before it starts let's
hope so
dear chunk okay oh oh oh this is how
it's gonna be
oh let's hope there's no Curie's but
stabbers in this whatever they wait what
oh wait
nowhere to hide mark well I'm pretty
sure I've got plenty of places to hide
and it's awfully damn dark and I don't
have a flashlight could I have a
flashlight please cuz otherwise I just
have to walk along this wall until we
run into it oh that's how it gonna be
oh well need I remind you mr. developer
Chris Hall I am an impenetrable wall of
impregnable manliness and that doesn't
mean that I'm unable to get pregnant
that means I'm in penetrable also it's a
fancy word impregnable bull bull I'm
smart and no big words I hit the wall oh
hello he's here who's here
what douche is here I'm just gonna
follow the wall until something happens
which I know you're gonna throw down
scare me I know you is so just get it
out of the way early otherwise I won't
be able to get on with my day and have
fun and not do this anymore
oh that's how it's gonna be oh yeah
that's gonna be huh but we're gonna do
you do that one Hey
well do bad not scary at all wait what I
thought it's something else on the wall
it's writing on the walls but it looks
like I'm just going back the way I came
I wonder if there's gonna be a mannequin
oh oh oh you're so oh you're a son of a
[ __ ] ain't ya oh I don't think I don't
hear those would leave open your Weebly
words I hear the wobbly wobbly Woo's
wibbly-wobbly whoo bleep where did I go
okay I can barely see anything I'm just
walking by hugging oh oh oh well no it's
gonna be mr. mannequin ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
let me guess the hallway is slowly gonna
become more closed in I'm gonna just
stand on your head until it's time to go
anywhere else so uh excuse me while I
just hop up here a little bit John oh
hey I almost got you yes yes come on
come on mr. mannequin you don't scare me
now I'm just king of the world there
what am I supposed to do I don't have a
flashlight I'm just standing on your
head for a bit better Boop okay so uh
about that so what am i doing what am i
doing welcome to the abandoned mannequin
Factory enjoy your stay oh really miss
narrator lady at least you're not as bad
as the Stanley parable 1 at least you're
not giving me the illusion of choice in
this event Oh God I can't see a damn
thing
now let's going on am I gonna get a
flashlight at any point here please
I'm just gonna have to hug the wall
you'll get to do that cuz hell is my
face
you'll get the jump scare with my own
face that doesn't mean I'm um I'm so
horrific Lee ugly that my own face
startles me it's just like every day I
get up what mmm what's that then hello
what is that supposed to be I can't even
tell some mannequin doing Gangnam style
over there there's a couple dead
mannequins anything and I can't go cuz
it's like glass oh hello what's all this
then I can't do anything with it I can't
do anything it's the way out oh wait was
this ah
markiplier came to a set of two doors he
entered the one on his left oh you son
of a [ __ ] you did this just because I
mention it then yo okay wait a minute
the developer knows that I would
probably not listen to the narrator ergo
I probably should listen to the narrator
while I'm not going through with what
the narrator tells me to do and since a
narrator wants me to go on the door the
left but I would normally not listen to
their there go in the right the actual
correct answer would be on the right but
if I choose that that it would actually
be wrong ergo I should go left
maybe markiplier was rewarded for being
obedient and was given a disco dance
alright enough dancing
everyone has their limit of dance breaks
of the craze but stabber the grace mutts
ever who but I'm tired from dancing I'm
literally out of breath I was dancing
for a lord whatever you need
markiplier your bot has been stabbed my
movement of the crazed give me a second
that's actually really well done the
voices beware the crazy oh god that's so
creepy
what is it doing this is it make any
sense
I'll just go I guess what everything Oh
creepy hello right light with wit a Oh
God likes all 5000 for charity good
totall does it mean as I go into the
Billy's
I don't know I don't know what okay I
guess I just got a look in the building
for coins and then get out of here where
there's so many buildings
okay so just give me the coins I'm still
out of breath from dancing Ted Danson
hello I got a coin that's good I guess
yeah no exit quite thanks it quick tired
hey I I'll probably edit it so that it
actually shows huh how much I was
actually I'm not gonna get through all
these houses and before the time runs
out how am I supposed to know it's gonna
be completely random know where the
codes are they always in this back room
over here no yes I don't know I'm not
gonna make it in time numbers what to do
this I'm not gonna make it in time hey
where's the coins give me a coin give me
a damn good ha yeah go go go
I don't have a sprint button I keep
getting calling all the walls oh my god
I'm in bumping their boudin build-a-bear
dee dee baby whatever do we buy be Bible
but but but but that day yeah my name is
everything baby De Niro
baby dabba doo baby never never never no
but oh come on stop getting caught on
the walls coins not gonna friggin make
it cuz I can kind of dammit ah coin
maybe there's a dubler in here no that
was probably just a waste of time I got
three coins and a hundred seconds to go
I'm gonna make it question mark there's
an easier way there must be an easier
way
oh god I'm not gonna make it many rows
of houses are there left no no no no no
no no just give me the coins oh god I
got three thousand dollars and not
enough time okay oh god oh god okay okay
panic attack and it okay there's only
one more row houses left I can make this
I can do this I can do this not going I
bet it doesn't have a double there's no
way that I was out of a double and I'm
gonna make him I'm gonna make a hunch I
bet the other one is in the last house
in this row I'm just I'm just I'm just
banking on this one I bet I back if I
was a game designer out but the last one
in the very last one to make it more
panicking for me yeah all the money has
been expected from my account
oh whatever charity I guess good I did
it oh wait this is interactive mark
Blair the game - thanks for playing
markiplier the game - I admit this was
random and odd but so it barked hey that
is why we all love them wow what a great
guy I will keep it short so you don't
have very much have a great day and
enjoy life a game by Chris Hall youtuber
the euphoric rager the lonely astronaut
I hope that's not copyrighted
okay anyone's got out the game music
but anyway thank you so much Chris Hall
for making this it was really fun um
there was some frustrating parts in
there but but I bet I bet I bet it was
y'all and good fun right okay so
seriously thank you guys and thank you
anyone who makes a game for me if you
got a game that you made and you want me
to play let me know like whatever way
you can email Twitter whatever just let
me know I'd love to play it I always
love to see these things and the great
things that come out of the community so
I really am touched if you want to play
this for yourself maybe find out what
the other choice did in the Stanley
parable one so I don't know so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Oh
in case we didn't know yeah you can tell
I mean obviously Wade made that during
drug for
yeah